[Music]
1600 Islands thick with greenery form a
maze of channels in the azure waters of
Ha Long Bay off northeastern Vietnam
first centuries this spectacular
seascape has inspired Wonder
[Music]
although people have lived in this
region for thousands of years most of
the islands remain uninhabited but these
coves and natural towers are rich with
wildlife the name how long is Vietnamese
for descending dragon according to one
legend when the Viet people faced
invasion a dragon flew down from heaven
to their defense the creature sprayed
not only fire but also emeralds and Jade
jewels that became the green archipelago
the rock formations are known as karst
for millions of years seashells and
sediments fell to an ancient sea floor
forming solid rock tectonic activity
raised the resulting limestone above
water later rain fallen rivers carved
valleys that flooded after the last ice
age creating this rare example of a
karst field at sea
features include caves and tunnels where
sea water has worn down the pillars the
[Music]
fantastic landscape also continues into
two adjacent national parks on cat ba
island and by two long bay
[Music]
you can go kayaking caving or even ride
in a seaplane to experience the majesty
of these enchanting tropical islands
[Music]